this episode has been supported by lamda
dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here last year
an amazing neural network based
technique appeared that was able to look
at a bunch of unlabeled motion data and
learned to weave them together to
control the motion of quadrupeds like
this Wharf here it was able to
successfully address the shortcomings of
previous works for instance the weird
sliding motions have been eliminated and
it was also capable of following some
predefined trajectories this new paper
continues research in this direction by
proposing a technique that is also
capable of interacting with its
environment or other characters for
instance they can punch each other and
after the punch they can recover from
undesirable positions and more the
problem formulation is as follows it is
given the current state of the character
and the goal and you see here with blue
how it predicts the motion to continue
it understands that we have to walk
towards the goal that we are likely to
fall when hit by a ball and it knows
that then we have to get up and continue
our journey and eventually reach our
goal some amazing life advice from the
AI right there the goal here is also to
learn something meaningful from lots of
barely labelled human motion data barely
labeled means that a bunch of videos are
given almost as is without additional
information on what movements are being
performed in these videos if we had
labels for all this data that you see
here it would say that this sequence
shows a jump and these ones are for
running however the labeling process
takes a ton of time and effort so if we
can get away without it that's glorious
but in return with this we create an
additional burden that the learning
algorithm has to shoulder unfortunately
the problem gets even worse as you see
here the number of frames contained in
the original data set is very scarce to
alleviate this the authors decided to
augment this data set which
trying to combine parts of this data to
squeeze out as much information as
possible
you see some examples here how this
motion data can be combined from many
small segments and in the paper they
show that the augmentation helps us
create even up to 10 to 30 times more
training data for the neural networks as
a result of this augmented data set it
can learn to perform zombie guerrilla
movements chicken hopping even dribbling
with a basketball you name it what's
even more we can give the AI high-level
commands interactively and it will try
to weave the motions together
appropriately
they can also punch each other ow
all this was learned from a bunch of
unorganized data what a time to be alive
if you're a researcher or a startup
looking for cheap GPU compute to run
these algorithms check out lambda GPU
cloud I've talked about lambdas GPU
workstations in other videos and I'm
happy to tell you that they are offering
GPU cloud services as well the lambda
GPU cloud can train imagenet to 93%
accuracy for less than $19 lambdas web
based IDE lets you easily access your
instance right in your browser and
finally hold on to your papers because
the lambda GPU cloud costs less than
half of AWS and aja
make sure to go to lambda elapsed comm
slash papers and sign up for one of
their amazing GPU instances today thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time